التوتر يرخي بظلاله مجددا على العلاقات
بين واشنطن وتل ابيب بعد مشاحنات بين
مسؤولي الطرفين ومره اخرى كانت الاصلاحات
القضائيه المثيره للجدل في اسرائيل سببا
في اشعال فتيل الخلافه الشراره الاولى
التي اشعلت الخلافه الجديده كانت تصريحات
نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لهاريس الاخيره
شددت على اهميه استقلال القضاء خلال كلمه
القتها في حفل اقيم في السفاره
الاسرائيليه في واشنطن بمناسبه الذكرى
الخامسه والسبعين الاستقلال الدوله
اليهوديه تصريحنا اعاد الى الواجهه معارضه
اداره بايدن لجهود الحكومه اليمينيه
المتشدده التي يتزعمها بنيامين نتنياهو من
اجل ادخال اصلاحات على القضاء في خطوه
كانت قد قبلت باحتجاجات شديده داخل
اسرائيل
تصريح كمال هاريس لم يكن ليمر مرور الكرام
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه فسرعان ما بادرت
الى الرد وهذا عبر وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي لكوهين رد لم يخلو من الحده
حيث قال فيه الوزير الاسرائيلي انهارس لن
تعرف كيف تجيب في حال سؤالها عما يزعجها
بشان الاصلاح القضائي وتابع انه لا يعرف
ما اذا كانت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي قد
قرات القانون ام لا مستطردا ان تقديره
انها لم تقراها
لعبه تبادل التصريحات بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث دخل ايضا
السفير الامريكي لدى اسرائيل على الخط
السفير الامريكي
صرحت باشياء تعكس رؤيه الاداره الامريكيه
حول القيام والسياسات المشتركه بين
الدولتين لعبه الشد والجذب بين الجانبين
هدات نوعا ما بعد ما عاد وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي لتلطيف الاجواء من خلال تغريده
اكد فيها ان لديه احتراما كبيرا للولايات
المتحده ولائبه الرئيس كما لهاريس التي
تعتبر صديقه لاسرائيل وتابع وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي بالقول ان الاصلاحات القانونيه
في اسرائيل شان داخلي ملفتا الى ان هذه
القضيه لا تزال
رهن مناقشه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات